c'est halloween et il ya quelques
semaines de cela on s'est amusé à faire
un truc que j'ai en tête depuis un an
qui est hyper ripoux c'est à dire que
j'avais mon fils qui avait une araignée
géante en fait télécommandé vous savez
quand une tarentule géante voilà et à
chaque fois je m'amusais comme mon fils
allait aux toilettes a envoyé la
tarentule et j'ai dit pourquoi on ne
ferait pas aux chroniqueurs et donc
regardé c'était dans les loges de tpm
p&o c'est çà çà çà bury depuis quelques
semaines
[Musique]
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous ne le pensez tout à
l'heure nous permettez moi de le
remettre tout à l'heure lors des doubles
tard mais ça y est on dirait qu'elle a
vu à dose de ouf
mais elle est magnifique cette tare on
tue soit je félicite le gars qui a eu
cette idée que de 2,2 franchement de
jouer non de jouer à deux gars qui a eu
cette idée
tu imagines que ce gars peut-être
maintenant les milliardaires il ya un
jour de la saint tropez comme as tu vois
et tu vois un mec sortir d'un bateau nos
forêts c'est lui qui a inventé la
tarentule l'écart frère il a fait un
écart tu le passes à bras des milliers
d'euros avec cette arme tu là il va
passer votre capital bientôt aujourd'hui
c'est l'inventeur de la tarentule et
roddick bien sûr aujourd'hui voitures de
sport / hôtel de luxe tout lui réussit
dans mes sauts rim états ou pas ça c'est
ça c'est une invention de ouf bravo à
ceux qui l'ont été par vous
[Applaudissements]